this is how you can feel alone in a
crowd and Hollow in Victory if you
haven't shown your true self to the
people around you you are inevitably
going to feel disconnected from them and
the people who would have fallen in love
with the true you will pass you by
because that person is never presented
Al Marcus said the Persona is incapable
of receiving love it can only receive
praise the Persona subsumes the person
this isn't the people around you's fault
you need to take responsibility for this
there are reasons to fear truly showing
up but they pale in insignificance
compared to the reasons to hide away
even if all that you want is Success
your highest point of unique
contribution involves you fully
embracing you forget the actualizing
yourself forward and offering the world
something which no one else can Nal
ravikant says no one can beat you at
being you the absolute best that you can
hope for if you're playing a role is to
be the second best in the world at being
someone else